hello everyone and welcome to the 2019
FIBA World Cup it's the second game of
the finals Tingler and vs. team
inaudible now Dean has the white pieces
and I don't know if I mentioned this in
the previous videos I thought everyone
was familiar with this but the finals is
four games classical so it's not to
classical games and then you go into the
rapids it's for classical games and only
then do you go into the rapids and hear
something very extraordinary happened
already before the first move was played
now I'm sure I'm sure a job prepared for
many things but what we will see now I
don't know if her job was ready for this
so I hope you guys are ready for it here
it is before the first move dingos for
the eye contact handshake there we have
it
Dean goes straight for the eye contact
and does not return the favor he just
you know shakes shakes the hand stares
at his pieces and I don't know it seems
like a pretty big deal you know such a
such a strong start to the game but yeah
we'll see what happens and it's not it's
not like all that much depends on the
final so to 2019 3d World Cup the semi
finals were much more important if you
win the semi finals you're into the you
go into the candidates tournament here
not it's not all that important because
you're already in the candidates both
doing another job of are in the
candidates and first first place is a
hundred and ten thousand dollars second
places are guaranteed eighty thousand
dollars so it's a thirty thousand
dollars difference but when you're in
the candidates and have a guaranteed
eighty thousand dollars everything is
easier Alberta still you do want to win
the World Cup with the white pieces ding
opens with c4 that with Knight to f6 the
English opening is on the board with
Knight to c3 e six and now II for the
Makino's variation with c5 better job of
and now II five pushing the knight you
you could either go to well not there
but g4 or g8 and there is one game where
g4 was played and black actually won the
game but everyone always goes nice to g8
so this is what a job does with Knight
to f3 and now Knight to c6
and the d4 just expanding in the center
we've seek a person before knife
characters
Knight characters on e5 now so giving up
a pawn a but for for some very nice
ideas Knight d2 b5 by the in going after
Knight to d6 check our job invites this
check he's very well prepared for this
line with a six attacks the knight nice
to d6 certain Bishop captures and Queen
captures and visas so you cannot offer a
trade right away because your knight on
e5 is hanging so first f6 this is one of
the positions where it's actually okay
to play f6 and the Dean continues Bishop
to e3 with the idea is Bishop to b6 you
kind of want to harass the black queen
and here the jobber plays in Knight to
e7 so it seems like you could trap the
black Queen Bishop to b6 but not really
as a job as we mentioned is very
familiar with this line will rush up the
b6 biting and now Knight to f5 offering
a trade captures Knight captures on d6
ding of course isn't interested and
there are two very famous games that
have reached this position both where
Gary Kasparov had the white pieces I won
a one against Aleksandr borovsky in the
1991 Linares tournament Kasparov won
that game he played Queen to c5 here and
also a game against the Koloff in 1988
World Cup where he again played Queen to
c5 and won that game as well but dingos
Queen to b4 instead it's not a new move
or anything it's just a different line
than Kasparov chose with Knight to c6
our job goes after the Queen once again
before offering the Queen trade we have
Quintus e5 and now Queen to e7 and here
ding started spending some time he's
trying to decide whether he wants to
capture the Queen or or maybe play
something else maybe Bishop to d3 first
maybe Castle queenside first and after
awhile he decides the Castle queenside
and he gives the black an option here a
job of he said a return of said in an
interview after the game that this is
where he forgot his further analysis he
didn't know which what was the better
move here but there there is no best
move here I mean there is but for for
human chess a lot of moves seem like a
good idea the best idea is just the
trade Queen's right away and but to do
that you also have to give up the
give back the extra pawn for example
Queen captures a bunch of characters and
now you will have problems developing
your queen side ha d how do you develop
the d5 square is nicely covered by white
you would have to play d6 give back the
pawn and then after Knight captures rook
captures you would continue development
Bishop to d7 but then you have to give
back the pawn but here our job says no I
accept the challenge
I play d6 and the Queen has only one
square since the Black Knights cover now
a d4 and III you have to go all the way
to a3 and by doing this Roger keeps the
extra pawn so he castles and the ding
just well we have castles of opposite
sides so best what you can do in in you
know situations like this is to attack
so ding starts with g4 we have nice to
h6 now putting pressure on the g4 pawn
and now rook the g1 now ding is ready to
push f4 h4 and continue the attack and
here there is a one game that reach this
position is from 2009 jonathan grant vs
david Eggleston where fi was played
black was even able to win this game but
here at a job of chooses Knights to f7
is the strongest move in the position
recommended by the engine keep him
keeping an eye on on the g5 square with
the Knight Queen and pawn and now he
says ok now let's see what the Dean can
do dink continues his expansion on the
Kings side
he plays f4 better job of continuous
development with Bishop to d7 and now h4
and here we have a 5 so rush up to d7
followed by a 5 and now after dink plays
g5 he continues attacking now we have
Quinta h8 ready to recapture with the
Jeep on AVG captures on f6 and now
really just Bishop d7 followed by a5 and
King it really seemed like Raja have
already had this position in his home
preparation it just feels like it's a
little bit blurry to him as he's really
not spending time with with any of these
moves and it's a really tricky position
the attacking you just you know casually
cold-bloodedly played Bishop d7 a5
wending is coming for you on the Kings
side seems very seems very prepared but
ok with Queen to b3 biding now the queen
is also
able to re-enter the game and we have
rook F the c8 now comes King to be won
by ding getting the King away from the C
file and now here a job of spent a lot
of time and not sure how much exactly
but I'm pretty sure it's over 10 minutes
and he played a 5 it's a very odd move
to play because with E 5 you lose
control of the d5 square you immediately
allow Knight to d5 but e 5 is not a bad
movie in itself only it would be a much
better move if you first capture on g5
for example F captures H captures and
now e5 and now you have pretty much the
same position only you don't allow white
to go 95 and capture on f6 right away as
now there is no f6 point and here by
playing d5 ok you do have Bishop the f5
check coming in the King for example if
he goes to a 1 then Knight B 4 becomes
very strong you will not be able to keep
good the night away with a 3 because
well you don't want to allow the a file
to open up so a lot of tactical ideas
for the Rajah go in this situation but
instead played ePHI right away and ding
didn't take much to go for Knight to d5
you do want your monster night there as
soon as possible
so first bishop the f5 check as planned
now you could either move the King or
block blocking allows quinta east 6 so
nothing really happens there if you
capture the Queen recaptures with check
so instead the ding just goes King to a1
he says my king is perfectly safe there
and now comes Queen to e6 better job as
his Queen is under attack on e7 we have
Quinta e6 and now the idea we mentioned
the G captures on f6 this is now
possible as a reserve of did not capture
on g5 before playing a5 but ok G
captures on f6 and now
ding could go for gosh up to G - right
away move the Knights to e3 and then
rush up to d5 this Bishop will be a
monster Bishop on this diagonal but he
first plays a three seemingly not not
allowing this night to come to before
but it's actually not an issue Knights
the before is the the best move for
black in this position for example if
you capture of course you're you're
getting destroyed the bishop covers will
be one you've just allowed this roof to
check you and if you don't capture it
then of
the game just continues you go knife the
III prepare the ideas that we just
mentioned it captures an f4 Knight
captures on f5 Queen chapters and now
Queen to f3 going after the b7 pawn
where you would be very safe but it's
important to note that you don't have a
perpetual here with tonight's the c2
check of course you don't want to go to
be one to allow losing over the Queen
you can go to King gay - and now night
before does not ensure you a perpetual
because you can just capture it and go
king b3 the king is very safe there and
well you're just down a piece so but
above all in all nights the before after
a three would be would be great for a
job of but instead he went to look 8b8
first and now we have brush of the g2
now thing is ready to play Knight back
to e3 and bring this Bishop over to d5
where it will just be a monster Bishop
we've looked g8 and now comes the
Knights the e3 as planned so here it's
not easy to decide what to do this
Knight is nicely pressuring this Bishop
and it's it's not easy to make a move
for black for example one such idea
could be Bishop to g6 but do you see how
white wins day for a job of goes Bishop
to g6 I'll give you a couple of seconds
for this one as it's a really nice idea
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on you know just
winning the peace and the game and for
those of you just wanna enjoy oh just f5
you you invite the Bishop back as black
will lose a piece here if you don't
capture it so you have to capture it and
only now brush up to d5 and the knight
and f7 and the Queen and the Bishop an
f5 are both guarded by the Queen so the
Queen will be overloaded Queen to d7 you
just picked it up nice characters on f5
Queen captures and now you eliminate the
knight on f7 and you want a piece for
example captures captures black has no
contra plate your upper piece everything
is everything is excellent
one thing that a job of could have done
here in this situation is the rook
character Sanji - if he wanted he could
have decided to give up the exchange in
the long night capture Sanji - now maybe
Bishop to e4 and then for example F
captures on e5 Knight captures on e5 and
now Knights the e3 we would
have this position we're doing is of
course better but it's it's a very it's
a very tricky position however he
decided for night study for and this
just allows them to really create a
powerful position for him he played
there's a cat for Sundy for first
eliminating the night with a cat person
before and now Knight captures on f5
with Queen captures on f5 and now dink
is creating the monster that should rush
up to d5 and it's not only that this is
a beautiful diagonal for the bishop your
knight is under attack you will always
have an eye an eye on the g8 squares so
the outer loop will never be able to you
know go to the g8 square and there's no
way for black to ever attack the White
King the White King is extremely safe
here this is unbreakable the Bishop
Guardian the c4 pawn this is just
beautiful
if Rajah go could somehow trade this
night for the bishop then maybe Albert
okay Roger Burgos rook captures and g1
we looked at first on g1 and now as your
knight is under attack you just bring it
back into the game with Knight to h6 and
here well of course more most people
would just go Queen to g3 here
threatening Sun Queen to g7 action but
black can actually defend this with
Queen to g6 so Dean plays the much
stronger Queen to b6 and now you're
threatening Queen to c7 if you allow
this it's game over
it's it comes with the threat of
capturing the rook and also the threat
of threat of Queen g7 checkmate
so the Jumbo has to go back we have
Queen to d7 but now you can't keep an
eye on everything Queen captures on d4
and now the material and the board is
equal dink
grabs his pawn back but he is left with
a much better position if you look at
this bishop just slicing you know the
board in in 4/4 pieces just beautiful
controlling everything keeping an eye on
the g8 Square which is extremely
important you you constantly have to
keep an eye on this rook has to keep an
eye on the squared own I have to keep an
eye on the square you have to be careful
if you remove them then Ruby it will
just be mate you have to keep an eye on
your f6 pawn Queen captures on f6 also
will be deadly so Queen to e7 you have
to defend it and now just king day too
position is so good that he takes this
opportunity to improve the safety of his
king and raja baath has to play a move
so what can he do he plays Knight to f5
he attacks dings Queen and now what do
you do here Queen d3 seems like a nice
idea attacks tonight on a5 but you get
Quinta III and now you cannot capture
due to Queen captures in g1
you would have to go back then go to g2
and then well threaten some ideas but
there's no point in allowing it so
instead the dingos Queen back to c3 the
a 5 point is under attack
and now a job of finally defended b6 now
there is no threat of Bishop Capra's and
b7 in the future so you can finally
bring your rook into the game and here
the time the situation on the clock is
ding eight minutes at a job of three
minutes and they still have to make
three moves until they reach time
control so it's a very intense position
here ding has to decide what to do he
decides for h5 which creates some
beautiful tactical opportunities he
could go for rook e1 attacking the Queen
and after the Queen moves the g7 he
could go for rook to e6 infiltrating and
going for this f6 pawn forcing black the
defend would rook to a fate and here by
all blacks pieces are just tied down
it's just a disgusting position for
black but being decides okay those are
doors are forcing lines and their job is
three seconds three minutes on the clock
let's just play a five h5 and allow him
to play whatever he wants and and spend
more time well I have a very nice
tactical idea
we've looked yet by the job of a sting
did not go for rook t1 our job claims
the e-file and now again ding just goes
h6 and here this is move 39 a job still
has to make two more moves to reach time
control but it's a it's a really hard
position to play for example if you
capture this do you see what the dings
idea was it feel free to pause the video
as it's a beautiful idea to find while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such a
beautiful amazing idea and for those of
you who just wanna enjoy it so it's
actually rook to e1 you just give it up
for example Queen captures and Queen
captures on f6 is mate because the
covers the g8 square on the other hand
if you don't capture it there really
isn't a good response Queen to f8 you
just play a rope capture sunny 8th Queen
captors and now Queen captures on f6 is
again mate
there's no way to defend this so after
h6 at a job of with very little time on
the clock played nice the e3 instead but
it makes no difference
ding just played rook to e1 and here
before reaching time control Tamura job
of resigned the game before making move
40 as there is nothing more to do here
whatever you play here dings next move
is the rook captures night and there is
no way to avoid this for example if he
plays anything rook captures and again
you will not be able to recapture or
just Queen captures here there's there's
there's no move here raja baath can make
so really a really an incredible game by
both of them and you know didn't just
improve the position a little by little
and it really seems like in that
position where a job had to decide
whether to allow the Queen's on the
board by pushing the Queen back with
winter d6 I'll just short in case anyone
forgot so here basically the opening
after 96 yeah but should be read there
we have it after Dean Castle queenside
d6 or Queen captures on c5 it seems that
already here I think things started to
go bad for a job of so it was better
just trade Queens and give up the d6
pawn equalized material then to allow
such a such a powerful position to
appear on the board but I think
definitely took his chances and he
converted it into a full point which
means he is the one step closer to
winning the World Cup two more game two
more classical games in between the two
of them will be played so we'll be you
know will be waiting to check him out so
yeah once again we could we could show
this very nice intimidating handshake by
ding really III mean I just love it so I
do hope you enjoyed it as well and I do
hope you enjoyed the game I would like
to thank Stanley Manuel Ramos
Rasmus also and wish the technology
services llc for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video serie thank you all
for watching and
I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the World Cup and of course
checking up on your suggestions so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day